one of the one of the main ideas that us
oliver stone pushes in the ukraine
documentary
um
i think it was the second one he had
there was two there was uh there was
ukraine on fire which was the first one
that goes up to which basically covers
maidan
um and then there was the second one
which goes all the way up to current
events
um with the election of the current guy
um
you means zelinski yeah he talks about
zelinski that's where the second
documentary ends but he he covers the uh
the 2016 u.s election uh pretty he was
pretty deep on it um
basically going back to the idea of how
ukraine
um
had a big part to do with this 2016
election and all the people involved
specifically he talks about hillary
clinton's
civil societies 2.0 program that she
created a secretary of state under obama
um
and the program was to train and fund
ngos overseas
yeah um one of the
ngos that she worked with directly was
called the international renaissance
foundation
which was funded by george soros
uh so was not funded by the u.s
government
no this this specific uh international
renaissance foundation was funded by
george soros and the us government
provided the training so we worked with
them we worked with them right to
provide the training um not specifically
the funding for that one
um
but this was part of the private email
network she set up was part of the civil
societies 2.0 program
which is
crazy something like this exists
um
and then
when you go to
you know what we talked already
poroshenko was very pro-clinton
anti-trump
um the investigations into ukraine
meddling broke out
paul manafort was
proven to be working directly with
the ukrainian party the party of regions
well that's manafort's uh that's yeah
yanukovych's party yanukovych's party
right yeah um
and
sergio leschenko was the journalist yeah
sergey lucianco sergey lashanko he was
the journalist who basically revealed
the receipts
from the paul manafort receipts on this
black ledger right
um
what was your view of all of this
when it was going down
well the black the the controversy about
the black ledger i'm familiar with that
and
and um
i don't think that any of this stuff had
much impact on the u.s uh election
the uh
you know knowing the region a little bit
as i do i my guess is that
the ukrainians
were influenced
this this is conjecture on my part so
you know take it for just
an educated guess
uh were influenced by the charges
against trump
that
in insofar as
trump was being accused of being a
russian agent
uh
they they took it upon themselves to do
what they could to help
uh hillary who was his political
opponent
and in particular people who had been
uh
part of that ngo world
in ukraine
uh
you know
may or may not have taken the initiative
to provide
dubious information
uh to undercut for example paul manafort
i mean
manafort was
an advisor to yanukovych now he ends up
advising trump
so that fit in with the kind of
narrative that was created that trump
was
uh
somehow under the control of the
russians the reality being however it
was that manif manafort uh
uh was
you know an uh political adviser to all
kinds of people right just yanukovych
and that
trump
presumably hired him not because of his
connections to russia but because of his
skill in winning elections which
which he had demonstrated
so i don't i think that this is just the
kind of you know as the layers of
intrigue and deception began to build
upon each other
uh
everybody got it wanted to get into the
act
that's now
the the black ledger as i understand is
false but
once again i have not
uh
i've not uh
investigated that in any depth i mean
there are certain things i have
investigated in depth that's not one of
them
in the documentary uh they talk when
they talk about the black ledger um it
had names of hundreds of people's
signatures on there with receipts who
are paid
in total you know hundreds of millions
of dollars
um one of the names on that black ledger
was manafort
yeah um and then initially so so the guy
uh leshanko the journalist
sergey lashanko the journalist slash
activist against against all corruption
he was eventually convicted for meddling
in the election
um and working with alexandra alexandra
chalupa who spearheaded this anti-trump
campaign and she was many people came
out said that she was like trying to
find dirt on trump to try to well a lot
of people were yeah and uh oh and by the
way
people would have been glad to get dirt
on hillary
uh it it surprises me a little bit of
how ineffectual they were because uh
that uh that information exists
but um
but you know the the the key thing to to
bear in mind here
is that when russia or russian
intelligence sees an opportunity
to disrupt american society they will
take it
[Music]
but that the opportunity is provided by
americans
our you know this is our political
divide the political hatreds
in this country give give
uh foreigners a golden opportunity
to weaken the country
uh as long as we don't respect ethical
norms in our own behavior as long as we
don't care about the truth
we'll find that we'll find plenty of
foreigners
who are happy
uh to to to use that against us and
exploit our weaknesses
what do you what is what do you think of
the idea that america is this
moral high ground of the earth of the
world and uh and you know russia is this
evil empire you know obviously it's no
one would argue the fact that putin and
the history has been
has been
evil throughout its existence evil
things have been done by all of these
leaders
and dictators
but
what
is
i guess what gives credence to the idea
that america is so much better and
america's morals
should be imposed throughout the world
well i think you hid it yourself when
you pointed out that we have nothing in
our history like the kind of horrors
that have
have characterized the history
of countries like russia and ukraine um
you know in ukraine
millions of people were deliberately
starved to death
but we don't have that here in the us
uh and you know in the soviet union
there was a great terror people were
um in the course of a about
a little over a year a hundred
seven hundred thousand people were shot
you know on on falsified charges who we
we haven't had that experience here
uh
you know they're they're
you know the nazis set up death
death camps and gas chambers i mean we
we we've never
built gas chambers here for
eliminating people
who are completely innocent right
so uh you know the case can be made that
that america being a stable democracy
and also
uh the most powerful country in the
world economically
is
is
not only
a good candidate for
world leadership but even is obliged
to assume that role for the sake of
everybody else
because we you know
other countries uh
i mean other countries talk about
american domination what they're talking
about is the ability of of democratic
ideals to to under undermine the power
of various dictatorial leaders
you